Peter wrote in what's the worst thing
you've eaten out of politeness okay I I
feel kind of bad about telling this
story because it relates to one of my
great-aunts I'm not gonna say exactly
what her age is because that would
identify which one of them it is then
they don't speak English but somebody
might tell them they I have a great aunt
who's you know in her late 80s to mid
90s let me just put it that way and
about twelve or fourteen years ago we
were a bunch of us in Argentina going
over to her house
have you heard pat of gefilte fish have
it okay the filter fishes not what she
made gefilte fish is a sort of
gelatinous loaf that is considered a
staple at most Passover Seder 's and
other events of the Jewish persuasion
and I never particularly disliked
gefilte fish more recently I've not
really liked the texture I didn't really
dislike a filter fish my great aunt ones
one of my great aunts once made
something that was similar to gefilte
fish in that it was a cold fish based
loaf but it had a very strange sauce on
top of it imagine a meat loaf but
instead it's a go filter fish loaf okay
huge takes up you know big pan and then
on top of it it has a sauce that I
couldn't describe specifically but it
seemed to be sort of a mix between
mayonnaise and ketchup which I think has
a name it might be harder sauce no
tartar sauce is relish and mayonnaise
okay
the vegan explaining to me what tartar
sauce is and it was it really wasn't
good it really wasn't good and I did eat
some of it but I think one of her kids
was at this dinner and sort of politely
suggested why don't we throw some
ravioli on the water as well and I think
that an alternative dish was created and
out of politeness I did eat it and it
really was not good it was it was
terrible and there's also an infamous
incident involving my dad and it's we
refer to it as the sloppy joe incident
and the sloppy joe incident is we were
relatively new to the D to the us being
vegan - Pat do you know what sloppy joes
are I know what sloppy joe is okay okay
I don't even I'm not even sure I know
and certainly when my dad made them it
didn't clarify let me put it that way
but my dad decided hey
we're in the u.s. he had apparently
heard about sloppy joes somewhere and he
decided we were making sloppy joes and
it was basically like a ground beef and
tomato sauce mister spooned onto
hamburger buns and it was a it was
absolutely terrible and he recognizes
that it's bad and to this day still
jokes that he might be making sloppy job
I'm like oh okay I'm gonna be around
I'll stop by for dinner and he's like oh
good we're having sloppy joes you know I
never really was much of a picky eater
before this whole new dietary constraint
that I've taken on right so I would eat
just about anything but I remember even
just a year ago that I had to go to this
social gathering where everyone has was
having Bloody Marys okay I found it to
be completely disgusting oh and like
tomato juice and some weird spices and
stuff Oh God and I just this issac it
just I downed the whole thing because
you don't want to waste alcohol right
but I still I still just drank the whole
thing as quickly as I could and I'm
never gonna have one again huh I'm
finding this story odd yeah and also had
haggis which is like leap heart and in
liver as long as that what turned you
vegan the hitch probably should have
been I've heard that haggis is horrible
yeah truly horrible and I've got a bunch
of friends that have visited Scotland in
the last couple years and they all say
it's absolutely terrible like I went to
Scotland I have to have the haggis right
it's just like a story is that one yes
oh you had it in Scotland huh okay yeah
and then once well my mom actually does
listen to the show sometimes so I'm not
gonna tell the raw chicken story we'll
cut that out
well cut yeah delete all mentions of
that from the version of this that you
eventually published